so did you see this on uh i think ctv
and then abc reared it
have you seen this video this girl
is talking about why she doesn't want to
wear a mask
right and this dude that she doesn't
know
walks up to her in the middle of the
interview and starts making out with her
and by the way plot twist she likes it
so check this out i feel as if
maths are not 100 important
i feel as if if i interrupted
a spontaneous kiss from someone that she
doesn't know
oh my god no i met him for a second with
my dog
that's insane are you all right yeah
she's not all right
she's in love did you see her snort i'll
tell you what though man gutsy move
[ __ ] it on camera gutsy move like that's
who boy but if
but he's a good looking guy if you're a
good looking guy you get away with a lot
that's insane are you all right yeah
he's so hot
i told you if you [ __ ] if [ __ ] i
did that i'd be in jail right now oh
yeah either one of us would be
[ __ ] prison for not even for like
battery it would be like
jesus zayn are you all right
yeah he's so hot having met just
minutes earlier jillian mccown says
she's okay with the kiss
we asked jack ring the man who initiated
the kiss if he's a
now you think she's stupid wait to hear
this guy aware of all the risks of
kissing a person you don't know
during a pandemic do you worry about
possibly either of you
having that contract me passing it
anything oh not not
just headed right now but yeah i
probably do right now but i think the
kiss was worth it
i lost she's got the accent
i was gonna say because i'm looking at
this guy and i'm thinking i think he's
just
worth it he's not uh like there's
nothing really special about this guy
and he's like
oh of course i'm going to stick me
tongue in her mouth you're like god damn
it
of course she wants to [ __ ] you you have
an accent
good i hate by the way look
hi everyone out here giving out about
this corona virus i'm just out here
licking bottles
and they caught it on film
i look
man ballsy i gotta say ballsy move
i look it paid off for him good for him
good for him but that is a ballsy
[ __ ] move man
to walk up but i you know the news thing
is like are you afraid about passing do
you don't think
people are still [ __ ] in on tinder
right now of course they are
like this doesn't change yeah because dr
faust said it was okay
yeah dr fauci said tinder was okay he
said guys
wear masks quit your jobs but [ __ ] is
okay
[ __ ] strangers that's fine look at
that just
went right in for that's um [ __ ] man
you wouldn't see me do you would have
seen me doing that 10 years ago easily
i used to do [ __ ] like that all the time
back and then
you like again 10 years ago bold moves
like this you could pull it off but
dude nowadays man oh boy you you are
you are one false move away from a
[ __ ] charge
because this guy does that you know you
do it now he gets away with it but
this is almost like a shoplifting or
something you know i mean like you might
get away with it the first couple of
times but
the first time you get like you could
rob a bank and probably get away with
robbing a bank
people are saying people are saying it's
staged but here's why i say it's not
her reaction right here oh my god
the snorkel no i met him for a second
with my dog
that's insane are you all right that's
snort
i don't think it's state and look i
understand everything on the internet's
fake and i get it
no i believe this this feels real yeah
but yeah that's what i'm saying man like
you you can't like i was saying you
could rob a bank you'd probably get away
with it one or two times
but you keep doing it man that's that's
what this is like this is almost like
the contact that cleveland robbing a
bank you get caught the one time man
that's gonna be the end of your [ __ ]
life
can't be doing that [ __ ] on [ __ ]
camera
or you shouldn't be doing it at all
let's be [ __ ] like you shouldn't be
randomly walking up the chicks that
you've met for five seconds and kissing
whatever it's [ __ ]
worked after world war two yes [ __ ]
but it's not though i mean it is after
world war ii but it's a different time
it's a different time and you just can't
get away with that i think i honestly
like i would
just like text me i would text her later
like i heard you snort and i was like
yes it's not going to work so sorry
[Laughter]
he just follows up by rejecting her yeah
sorry that's snort killed it for me